my old enemy you cannot hide from me no
matter what form you choose to wear let
your true self be revealed Diablo it's
that time again to talk to you about the
latest games in new releases and this
week you get to go back to sanctuary as
your old self whether that be a witch
doctor barbarian wizard monk demon
hunter or the Crusader with the fifth
act from diablo 3 Reaper of souls
explore new worlds using your new powers
like Tiffany Avalanche and clearly the
best power ever piranhas join the
crusade March 25th
this week you get to meet a real witch
that earned her title in more ways than
one with the witch and the hundred
knight this JRPG takes you through the
various areas of medea spreading your
witchcraft and swampland wherever you
please you run on pure Giga calories so
eat up fatty spare me become a metalia
worshipper March 25th also this week you
get the run-and-gun style of metal slug
with an addictive weapon crafting
mechanic in mercenary kings this has
been available to play thanks to early
access but it now comes out with more
content and tighter controls coming out
on pc this tuesday with the plan to come
out on ps4 april first which will either
be a great day for ps4 owners or one of
the worst April fools day jokes in years
let's kick it up a notch with the latest
blazblue 2d fighting game with chrono
phantasma now available in North America
Arc System Works offers seven grand
spanking new characters each with their
own deadly weapons fancy dress style and
awesome drive my favorite of which is
the spiral that creates a giant drill
awesome you can crush trigger March
twenty fifth and finally you get to help
out one hell of a smart agile and good
looking goat as far as attractive goats
go with a scapegoat to this 2d puzzle
platformer uses the assistance of a tiny
Mouse friend to try and escape a
labyrinth style prison get your goat on
March 24 for further details visit
gamespot's new releases page release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change see you next week
you